Alo Alo
Alo ạ
ô ồ cái À cái kia nó tự động mà gửi số
rồi kìa Hay vãi nhưng mà đây với điều
kiện à
Mở obs lên chưa cầm chực bật start cái
gì cả nó cứ nhảy
Ừ vậy cũng được
ờ
ờ Xin chào các bạn ở Hôm nay thì các bạn
đang thấy thì hôm nay mình sẽ dạy về out
tức là kiểu là mình cũng không nhớ au nó
là gì lắm chỉ biết được Lại Khai có đăng
nhập trong đấy Đăng nhập đăng xuấtđăng
ký cái gì đó chị sẽ làm hết trong ao
thì hôm nay cũng chưa Tôi có hứa là hôm
nay sẽ cài luôn cả cái thư viện này ra
tổ chức ai đâu Chị sẽ
ai Có code đây của tôi nữa chắc tôi sẽ
phải
hỗ trợ công ty đã hơn một tí nha
à à
này không ạ khi cài thêm viết thư viện
này về để có thể đăng nhập bằng mạng xã
hội khác cụ thể là ghi thấp cả written đ
Ả Rập chỉ có thể là ghi Phát
đăng ký trước cho mình mới làm tí năng
đăng nhập
rõ là mình đã có tài khoản đâu đúng
không ạ Mình sẽ làm đăng ký chưa
Ồ không tôi nếu mà tôi mà bận quá cho
tôi sẽ báo trước mấy ông có chuyện đồ
sát thì tôi phải báo Mấy ông chứ không
hiểu được nhưng mất tới đâu tôi chẳng
qua thôi vừa Mẹ ăn không Không hôm nay à
hôm tôi lên công ty vào hôm thứ Hai và
thứ năm sẽ thành công ty tôi có cái kiểu
lịch vị như thế nhập hai đó là chỗ không
ép nhận là không em nhân riêng ở bên
công ty anh em đã làm được tại nhà
có gì à anh em đăng ký hôm nào lên thì
lên nói chung họ bây giờ đang trên thần
tự nguyện để cho anh em lên gần công ty
về hơn gần một năm ở nhà rồi thì công ty
tôi đăng ký
công ty tôi đang khuyến khích là lên là
thứ hai thứ Năm Hôm nay tôi mới lên công
ty xong ngồi bên công ty ngồi cốt xong
rồi
mệt quá về ngủ bây giờ mới dậy
text Editor dù vậy ạ hả Thấy cái tờ thì
sẽ làm sao máy tách em Bây giờ tôi đang
dùng pp Zone nói de e
cô
giáo cái hàm xuống dưới cho đẹp này
à à
ở đó cho cân cân nhỉ Có được khó chịu
không
Ừ
ok à
làm gì cái thư viện này xong thì ra vẫn
chưa đủ đâu cái thư viện này mới chỉ ở
mức tương đối còn là ông muốn sử dụng
anh ở đây
em có cả mấy cái rồi thì phải Hình như
thế
Ừ để thử xem nhé
mẫu nó này đâu code này chuyển mức tương
đối thôi mình sẽ phải dùng kiểu kiểu nha
à
thứ hai tôi dậy người ông mưa bão nhỉ
cho tôi tôi chưa dùng nha Bây giờ nếu
thế tôi sẽ mò cùng mấy ông nhé
à vì cốt ở đây nó có vẻ là có vẻ là dễ
thế thử dùng cùng với ông nhá
đại khái thì cái này cái bản chất à đăng
nhập bằng mạng mạng xã hội khác bản chất
nó gì Cái cái văng nhầm mã số khác thì
nó sẽ gọi kiểu oa kiểu ngay tức là sao
nghĩa là thay vì nó đăng ký ở trên trang
mình xong rồi nó xác nhận Ví dụ ở Đang
xác nhận bằng Email cái gì đó chiến
tranh Mình ở ạ thì nó sẽ dùng qua mạng
xã hội thứ ba nói chung thẳng thứ ba thì
mà nó xác nhận hộ mình nhiều đấy rồi và
bên đấy cũng cũng lấy thông tin
thông tin của người dùng rồi nên nó sẽ
gửi lại cho ông một vài cái thông tin
đấy nghe mấy ông hoàn toàn này dùng được
anh cần như thế à
như không cần phải cài thêm cái á ờ ờ
không cần cài thêm nếu mà Mấy ông chỉ
dùng vài cái này như thế
à Còn nếu mà Mấy ông muốn thêm thì mới
ông sẽ vậy Vào trong này ông Xem cụ thể
đi chùa Ông muốn đăng nhập bằng tài
khoản google mà google nhỉ Google này có
Facebook này nó là sự Apple đi ông phải
cài thêm cái này chẳng ạ ạ
thì ra mọi cái đây nó đều có cái thêm
nhưng mà chắc là có sẵn ở trong cái xe
buýt rồi Vậy thử nha đi xe buýt à
anh chưa có gì đúng không Thì bên này
ông sẽ copy ở đây này
à à
Ừ có gì này đó sau đó thì ở ông sẽ phải
trình pha nv ở đây và điều hướng quay
trở lại của ông sẽ điều hướng gì của tôi
thì sẽ là webtec chấm test các thứ thứ
và thực ra không có bảo mật thì cả nó HD
cực phê trong này hptf Nhưng mà nếu mà
tí Nếu mà áp này yêu cầu cái video cái
có bác cái điều hướng quay trở lại mà
phải là Linh https hoặc là Linh đấy phải
được xác ướp cái gì đó thì tôi sẽ fake
IP áo 7 fake IP mà dùng một cái app thứ
ba để mà
để mà kiểu topic ấy ạ Cái ip của tôi ra
ngoài
A và được an này copy cái ip của tôi ra
ngoài mấy ông thì xem cái này
đây mình thử nhé có tiền thì mình sẽ
phải tải tạo tài khoản cái clip này
đi khắp
ông có cha nha hát này hầu như thế này
là được đấy
Hà
được có xinh đấy bảo mật gì không
Ừ chiều nay hơi nguy hiểm về bảo mật
ở
đâu xem nào
ừ ừ
những điều Rắc Rối
Ăn nhiều cho thằng ở đây mình sẽ là
web môi giới
khi đấy nhé Cho nghe Huy Hiệp
bắt buộc phải có không test cái gì đó ờ
ờ
a web
à à
hướng quay trở về thì mình sẽ là gì
nhà hàng ngày là thằng Tý hấp nên là
mình sẽ với mỗi một hàng thì mình sẽ
phải điều hướng về cái riêng không ạ Tôi
có thể gộp chung nó lại là
truyền lên truyền lên đây một cái gọi là
tên của cái thằng đấy sau đó đi lấy về ở
đây
ở ngã đây là tôi sẽ ra
ở đâu này
chỉ có bác này
em
đổi kèm heo ý thấp hàng ạ này
đã mở
khi sex
à à
đồng hồ
có cái gì đó thôi Không biết được nữa cứ
kệ đi bỏ qua
ờ ờ này này đi này
dự báo mình có offline này đi mấy ông sẽ
thấy là nó sẽ gọi đến phải nv ở đây bởi
vì thường cấu hình mấy con thích thì
mình ông sẽ biết được trong file nv để
tớ biết rồi đây
đi họp Ryan này bằng này
a mile Suite đúng không
từ ngày thừa không được phép về lộ Nhưng
không sao thì áp này vừa nói chẳng có
cái gì cả
anh không nhìn ngang mình không có nhanh
nhá Ờ tiếp theo là
con gà nó ra khi hấp có bác nữa Nhưng
cái này mình hay bỏ qua riêng trường hợp
này mình thấy bỏ qua tôi thường hay xóa
cái đi Tại sao thì định là mình cái tôi
đích của mình đã khai báo ở trên này rồi
Nhớ thế không cần lấy cái báo về đâu
phải trả tao cũng đi
này thậm chí có khai báo kiểu này được
nhà chẳng tác dụng được Xóa đi à
Ừ Rồi mình sẽ có một router Mình có 1 lô
tô để mà xử lý các bộ này thì tôi ở đây
router này
nhá điều hướng quay trở lại ZicZac
l redirect này
cả là
khi cài đặt ở đây là một cái là không
finder là nhà cung cấp thường hay đặt
tên ở nhà mày không ạ này
ạ
sau đó thì
nhá
router để điều hướng sang nhà cung cấp
này
Ê pete ơn đấy mới đúng chứ cấp nhầm này
à à
xe điều hướng quay nhảy sang ngày sửa
lại ở phố Rider OOO
ông Donald bordo thức ăn để trả lời từ
đây này Rider lấy dưới đây này chuyển
vào đây này nhớ đây trong trường hợp là
mình hội mình có thôi kiểm tra sẽ là hãy
chọn là mình phải kiểm tra xem hài có
thì mình điều hướng thì nó mới chuẩn Gửi
rõ là bây giờ vừa rồi mấy ông thấy tôi
chỉ cấu hình mỗi khi áp không cấu hình
cái thằng khác thằng à
đó mình chưa cấu hình
ờ ờ
đi học Mình không cần lấy thêm thông tin
gì cả Mình không cần lấy thêm gì cả
về quê lấy thêm rất nhiều cái từ cái này
xe hoa một ngày hai
bên này cái này của tôi sẽ có cái nút
đăng nhập bằng nhà
bằng giấy Tháp trong cung ngầu đúng
không ạ sẽ
Ừ cái hyper rồi nha tôi mở lại hay pro
nhé Không biết nó có cái hình à cho nó
kiểu gì mấy thằng ngày đều có hỗ trợ về
cái á ảnh hình các thứ thứ
dai có cái này trông xịn hơn này biết
hết mình lấy cái bên này
không
Ừ ừ trao đổi đồ vẫn kịp mà đổi bắt ạ
khi sex
anh xin lỗi
ừ ừ
xịn
ở bên Masters ngay Master vọng có mấy
cái đấy rồi
sửa à
không cần logo ở đây như cái này của bác
ra rồi cơ
ở bển xem nhé mẹ này
dịch
vụ Huy thấp này à
môi giới việc là nó đi này
cho nó
vì Trông cũng đẹp mà tôi không có ảnh
thôi
ờ ờ
ừ ừ
Cái này công ty dung Tôi không nhớ phải
mua hay không Nhưng tôi chia sẻ miễn phí
mấy ông mà mạng mày không lên Linh lại
có mặt ở
gái anh mất rồi nhưng mà thế này trong
ngày hai mà không bắt chúng đẹp mà Mỗi
tội cái cái khác trong hơi xấu ở trên
bác này
kệ không sao Ờ
cái tháp này
Ê mày cấy mạng xã hội này tôi thứ hai
với hàng Facebook và tôi nhớ thằng khó
nhất để làm cái vụ mà
xin quyền đã nè Tôi sẽ không hướng dẫn
mấy ông và thực ra tội không không định
có ý định là làm cái đấy
không phải đi làm đăng nhập bằng lít H2
Mấy cái mạng sổ tôi sẽ phải đi vì mà
mình sẽ chỉ đăng nhập bằng cái gì mày
không nhớ không ạ và ly cân nè ở get
help with nát này mẹ cái kia bỏ qua
biết chả có cái cái đi chẳng có
khi có lửa
Ừ có gì nhỉ Hay không có xơ cô ấy nhỉ nó
thử nhé
Có gì nhỉ
à à à quên quên quên
Đăng ký kết cái lỗi gì mà đúng rồi
à à
ở tôi một tí
mở cửa hàng Bè hàng ngày đều đúng không
Thêm một tháng nữa này
số vietlott bây giờ không có gì phải
Thành làm nó bị như thế này vậy
đúng rồi nhờ thằng viết tắt không có
chị xem nào ạ
ừ ừ
khi họ ở bệnh nhân bệnh nhân
à à
Trang Mình là cốt mục đích là để cho
người dùng có sẵn tài khoản đấy để đăng
nhập mà
ở nhà có nhã tôi khuyến khích mấy người
có tài khoản get her feet lag vãi cả đi
cần mà chứ không phải là người dùng
Google đó người dùng Google ạ được thì
đương Hạnh có rồi Nhưng mà quan trọng là
mình đang muốn người ta
lệnh cho mình còn muốn lấy thông tin từ
từ Trang Mấy cái mạng xã hội tiên ở
trong này cho hướng đến của mình là gì
thôi à
này đã
ăn xong có bị không có ít lát nhà
ý em nói không có cái à
em
Ừ vợ không hiểu sao nó lại bay lên trên
kiểu này
lại nhỉ
à à
tôi mò về vụ này xanh Ừ nó bị can thiệp
gì không Tại sao nó bay trên
ừ ừ
Ê thằng này không lại nghỉ à
phải là kiểu
anh ở đây Lát mới đúng chứ
Á
đù đù Xin lỗi lỗi tội của tôi
trong ngày bọn đấy nhỉ
à à
em ạ đề cái gió cái nền nó bộ đồ second
family I
anh khóc chống tệ hôi bỏ đời thằng vừa
nãy là cái gì nha bộ đồ hàng ngày Ai bảo
sau này có mấy cái đại diện thôi
mua đồ
à à
như thế này
Ừ nhưng mà nếu mà secondary nó dạy bị
biến thành màu ghi trong nó hơi tệ info
for khi trong nó vẫn thế
ừ info trong Đỡ hơn cái anh Cháu đỡ hơn
ok
đang muốn giữ cái nên đắt này à
em
làm cái link nữa à
ừ ừ
gà trống chị nói
thể này
mình sẽ bên mình sẽ sửa lại cái router
của nó mình sẽ sửa lại ô tô điều hướng
đến giúp ở bây giờ với ghi tháp này mình
sẽ à
A lô tô này
chị
sẽ TN tháng ngày
Việt Nam này à
ý là how reflect này à
sau đó thì mình sẽ truyền cái ba là
master và
đó là do Rider
nhớ không lầm nói chuyện ngay đâu nó kít
hạt nha Cho bạn thôi cũng được thì thôi
anh ở đây đó ở bấm vào đây nó sẽ điều
hưởng đến cái
xe
tải Jac điều hướng
à à
anh vẫn phải cần một cái điều hướng đậu
xanh
chị xem nhé
30 Tết
nhớ lại cái lôgic cái đoạn này phát
vẫn hoa sữa trong ngoài cho dù nó hơi vô
dụng tôi thấy nó hơi bị tùy ý
ờ ờ
cái chung một cái à đâu tôi chung để mà
điều hướng
I wrote ở đây được
tôi một tí Mình sẽ có một cái trang là
à à
gửi nhá Nghe thử nhé á
đạt reflect Nhưng thực ra nó có bác viết
khi nghe tôi 16 là ai đi chọn A nó ở đây
này chuẩn do chúng ta sẽ phải còn cái có
Bác ở đây này
ở đâu ko bác này à
cái này sẽ em mình sẽ làm gì đó Ở đây
chồng ạ Đây
Ờ Ờ
Ừ cái này là kho bác này tôi sẽ gọi ở
bên này Roto này
ờ ờ
hào phó Bác
ở đây mình sẽ truyền vào tham số thứ hai
là khi thấp
Âm Nhạc
ở Mỹ hiểu được mà xe điều hướng về đây
ta lại cho anh nha
ừ ừ
Tik Tok
à à
Ừ Ừ hình như là không trong cái con tích
là luôn chạy trước thì file web này
không khai báo với cậu này khó chịu nghỉ
tôi gọi một hàm chung đi
Ô
thế không làm đi chỗ làm tắt được rồi
à Tôi đang định ở cẩu bởi vì nói chung
kiểu kia thì gọi được cái này không được
thì đưa mình sẽ lại phải
chi phí còn ai vậy
lyrics tên nó không hợp lý lắm à
anh về đây một cái Linh Trung đi cái là
chỉ có bác
Ừ nó
à à
đ.nv này
a smaller nối với à
sau mình thêm mấy cái homefinder mới thì
mình chỉ cần thay đổi cái này là được à
Ừ nó
kia mình cần xác nhận cái này nó sẽ gửi
một cái áo topten về và nó sẽ điều hướng
về đúng cái Lung Linh ở bên này mà tôi
thử rê đô Rio de cho mình xem nhé á
áp kèm cái Token mà từ tao cái này mình
sẽ lấy được toàn bộ những tội những cái
thông tin này đó Alo ok chưa thử cái là
nó trả về rất nhiều thông tin những thứ
ba thì mình không cần toàn bộ những cái
thông tin này mình sẽ cần cái gì mình sẽ
cần là thường là nó sẽ gọi ít mình sẽ
lấy
lấy thông tin để thông tin từ mày cái
hàm có sẵn của nó còn những cái thông
tin kiểu nghe này hãng sẽ lấy những cái
này nó thường là nên lấy ID mới dùng lưu
lại đi người dùng rất tốt để mà về sau A
về sau có thể trọ đến được người dùng
trong một vài trường hợp thôi Đối với
hàng Facebook thì đây áp ID user ID nên
là cũng không không từ cái ID này không
chui ra được người dùng thật nhưng mà
tôi không biết được hàng này nha thưởng
nha đi h.com này
Anh thường u xơ vải chéo nhé không được
này
anh không được này đấy Có về đây uses
phải đi Có vẻ thế nữa không Không ra
được không ra được người dùng thực
em có thể lấy từ yeah lạnh đường này ồ
có phải lấy được từ HTML là xem
cũng được
bình tĩnh nha Bình tĩnh nha tao mình sẽ
xem lại một tí trong database của mình
áo bóng đá tay của mình có
vì mình đã không mình lại không có một
Linh đây Linh ạ và cha ở đây Tôi đang
muốn làm gì Nếu giả sử là vừa rồi tôi
bảo muốn lưu lại linh của người dùng rất
là mình sẽ đưa link trong này
Ừ ông Linh đây không phải thường tôi
thường đấy mày không biết là họ thường
là nó sẽ chơi Cái trò này nó có có vài
công ty sẽ chơi mỗi chó khác nhau về cái
vụ đăng nhập bằng mạng xã hội này là tôi
sẽ gửi nói các trường hợp cho mấy ông
nhé
anh em ấy ông hình dung hơn nha
ở trường hợp thứ nhất này nói trường hợp
dễ thì mình sẽ là
đăng nhập bằng
mạng xã hội đúng không ạ
từ mạng xã hội thì nó còn những gì xảy
ra là lấy mail đó
em kiểm tra trong cơ sở dữ liệu
mà Cụ thể là trong bảng Oh dơ là là đã
tồn tại thì email chưa Nếu mà nếu mà tồn
tại rồi
Ừ thì đăng nhập
thằng ngu dơ kia
và gắn
số tài khoản
không Nó Xuân lưu lại tài khoản luôn
trong trường ở đây
Còn nếu mà chưa thì đăng ký bằng Email
đấy
thực ra là cái vụ này cái vụ này Nếu mà
nếu mà mời ông rồi để ý kĩ tôi có nói đó
là
anh cái đăng nhập bằng mạng xã hội này
giả sử đăng nhập bằng Facebook Facebook
cho anh ạ với cái email là j
tien@gmail.com để ạ thế này không ạ là
sử này nông nghiệp vào lúc đầu chưa có
tôi sẽ đăng ký bằng Email đấy ok rồi sau
đó lần sau tao đăng ký tôi đăng nhập lại
lần nữa
bằng cái mạng xã hội Facebook và email
này thì tôi sẽ đăng nhập thẳng vào luôn
uzuriel không ạ Đúng chưa đó sau đó thì
nếu một lần sau tôi không dùng Facebook
tôi dùng bằng tài khoản
Google Mạ cũng với cái email này đúng ạ
Nó sẽ đăng nhập tôi thẳng vào luôn yêu
dơ kia mà mà rõ ràng là với người dùng
cũ người ta hiểu đó là người ta đăng ký
bằng mạng xã hội Facebook chứ không phải
bằng Google và Nếu giả sử là
vì Nếu giả sử là
thằng kia bị mất cái tài khoản Facebook
mất tài khoản Google không ạ Nghĩa lúc
đầu đăng ký không Facebook ạ nhưng mà nó
bị nó bị mất tài khoản Google rồi Đúng
gia sử gia xử thế thôi Chứ thường mà
cùng một email chắc là không có trường
hợp bị mất thế đâu nhưng Giả sử thế
ngược lại cũng thế là sửa Thằng này đăng
ký bằng bằng tài khoản Google Đông ạ bởi
vì email này sau đó thì nhưng mà nó bị
mất Facebook rồi thằng khác nó dùng
Facebook thời đăng đăng nhập vào trên
cái mạng xã hội ở lại được bởi vì rõ
ràng chỉ thông qua kiểm tra Email mà
không hề kiểm tra xem là người này đã
từng đăng ký bằng mạng xã hội này hay
chưa có thể vào được luôn tài khoản đấy
thì thời gian nó một thứ khá nguy hiểm
mấy ông nghỉ không ạ Mấy ông ở đây có
khi đã từng có vai ông mất Facebook rồi
thôi một lần nhiều lần rồi đấy thì nó
cũng sẽ hiểu cái bài toán này ý nghĩa
tài khoản kia nói chung từng bị mất trải
qua nó chưa đổi được cái mail và nói
dùng cái tài khoản Facebook đấy mà đăng
nhập bằng mạnh vào những cái nên bản
khác thì cậu hiểu ngay đăng nhập vào
mạng xã hội như này mà vào được tài
khoản của ông đấy thì nó rất là Nguyên
cho tôi Tôi đang nói cái trường hợp rủi
ro đấy thôi tự nhiên là trang trang web
của mình không không đi lỗi kiểu cũng
chẳng còn mất gì cả em cũng không đáng
lo lắm nhưng mà tôi đã từng thấy rất
nhiều trang web làm theo cơ chế đơn giản
như này nó đơn giản thì đúng là bởi vì
không còn yêu dùng không cần yêu cầu
người dùng Đăng nhập đăng ký lại nữa
đúng ạ
Ừ nhưng mà nó lại hơi nguy hiểm
việc là là rõ ra người dùng lúc đầu đăng
ký bằng tài khoản Google thằng ạ mà đăng
nhập bằng Facebook nó lại vào được chỉ
vì trùng email thế thử là sai sai khi mà
người dùng hiểu đấy Đúng rồi Ông kia rồi
Đúng là phải lưu lại theo phố vài đâu
chứ không phải là lưu lại theo email
không đấy thì nó là trường hợp thứ 2 đó
là
ở trường hợp thứ 2 ở đây nó lại xảy ra
hơi áp một tí đây thì ông
ở đâu nhà ông à Ừ ông lấy email kiểm tra
những ngày Vân không ạ
email nó được unique nữa còn đấy mà
không uống nick thì chúng ta sẽ còn nữa
à
ở đây này đợi tôi một tí
ở trường hợp thứ hai là an toàn hơn nhé
nhớ sẽ là như này à
thì nó sẽ là không không đưa lại theo
email mà lưu lại id id mà tôi vừa nói
sau đó kiểm tra xem appid đấy đã tồn tại
ở trong tận trong đấy chưa sẽ như này
lấy áp ID của cô Vaio trong trường hợp
này quê đô thị Facebook vào Google nó
thôi kiểm
tra trong bảng mỗi cái bản gì đó cái
bảng ở đây là bạn ho những ngày sáng ạ
Đấy bảng này nó sẽ có những cột như nào
nó cột à áp ID
của Vidal
này sau đó thì ozid nhà tôi là sao nghĩa
là kiểm tra xem là với cái ID với cái đi
này
A và khớp với cái tao hận ví dụ Idol đầy
lý Tháp chẳng hạn thì đã có uzone này
chưa nếu có rồi thì đăng nhập rồi Loser
đấy còn nếu chưa có thì mình sẽ tạo anh
mới xong rồi sẽ đăng ký một teaser mới
hoàn toàn cái kiểu như thế nếu có hiểu
không
Ừ nhưng mà có cái bài toán ở đây đó là
nó cũng giống như là cái thằng à topcv
đã từng làm gần đây topcv thì phải đúng
không
ô tô tv Nó là đây Tôi cho mày không xem
luôn đây là sự tôi đăng ký tôi đăng nhập
bằng tài khoản Facebook thì tôi dùng cái
Email timolol thì nó là một cái tài
khoản khác từ đăng nhập bằng tài khoản
Google cũng như tin nữa lồ nó lại một
tài khoản khác đấy Thực ra thế thì lại
không tốt lành lẽ là mấy ông cũng còn
phải hỏi nữa đó là mấy ông ạ
Ê mấy ông sẽ phải đây đây Thì đang nói
rồi đó là mấy ông sẽ phải phải sắc thuộc
lại cái vụ email đấy là để cho mình mình
có thể hỏi lại email nghĩa thứ nhất là
vẫn nên có cái này nhá vẫn nên có thằng
này nhé
Ừ nếu mà hoàn toàn à Cái you ready này
vẫn được phép chung chung mà là sử
adidas123 này sau get hấp này giờ đi một
này xong rồi fly24 là nhãn tài khoản ở
Facebook
sử dụng cụ kozo ID vẫn là một và có thể
vẫn thể này được mà em chỉ là ông sẽ
phải liên kết các tài khoản của ông với
với
222 mạng xã hội kiểu kiểu như thế đấy
cậu như thế nghĩa là khi mà đăng nhập
vào thì ông kiểm tra xem là vẫn vẫn lấy
email sau vụ này nha ông vẫn lấy email
kiểm tra trong đấy lại gần nhà vẫn copy
về này kiểm tra cho Bảo user Nếu mà rồi
không phải đăng nhập bằng thằng ngu dơ
kia đâu mà sẽ là
hỏi xem
Ừ cái cái cái mạng xã hội kia
không không không không cần phải hỏi mà
gần như là kiểu dạng là liên liên kết
liên kết hay mạng xã hội vào một trong
người uống rượu ấy Kiểu kiểu thế Hỏi hỏi
xe mà bạn muốn liên kết không và vẫn
phải gửi một cái email compair nữa về
chính cái tài khoản email này để mà xác
thực xem là hai vẫn còn quyền để truy
cập vào email không dàn nó mà còn quyền
truy cập vào Email thì toàn bộ mạng xã
hội cùng với mail này phải mất hết rồi
đấy
anh nhé
vnes là gì đấy
Ừ nếu không hiểu thì tao không để hai
cách mà tôi từng thấy ở nhiều cái trang
đăng nhập bằng mạng xã hội mà tôi thể
suy ra được cái bài toán nói như thế rồi
có rất nhiều trang bây giờ vẫn còn đang
vụ là à
sẽ dùng một cái dùng một cái kiểu à
từ mạng xã hội nào được cái email về rồi
Kiểm tra như thế này này nên làm như tôi
vừa nói nó khá là nguy hiểm đúng ạ ạ
Ừ ok
Còn dùng cách 2 này béo thấy là đương
nhiên độ phức tạp nó hơn và thực ra là
người dùng lại phải xác thực lại nếu mà
giả sử là bằng đăng nhập bằng mạng xã
hội khác để như thế thậm chí là nó còn
là đều hơn giống như hạt topcv này nó
lười nó kiểu dạng là nó lưu lại là kiểu
Audi hay cái gì đó Nói chung là tạo hẳn
một thằng Cruiser mới ra thế không tốt
không tốt ngoạn nếu mà làm được tích hợp
lại giống như tôi vừa bảo thì nó tốt
nhất đúng không ạ Nó vừa tránh rủi ro mà
vừa tiện người dùng
à tiện mình dùng hơn nếu người dùng muốn
gặp gặp tài khoản Nếu không hiểu cho anh
ấy
Ừ nhưng mà bây giờ thì tôi lười nên là
tôi sẽ rồi kênh 10 cả
ờ ờ
tôi định lưu lại cả
linh của người dùng như này cơ không này
mình sẽ phải tạo thêm 12
một vài cục riêng để lưu lại
để tôi xem nào
bài hát nếu muốn coi làm cái bột Đã kết
hay trách hay tôi tôi tôi từng làm để
hai cách rồi nhưng cái quan trọng à
hai con thằn làm mấy ông có tải được hay
không thôi chứ thực ra là cái cái à
Ừ cái mục đích của cái việc làm này nó
là tôi đang hướng đến nó mới ông đúng
nghĩa bằng cấp với tôi trình độ bằng cấp
với tôi nghĩa Suneo nghĩa là mấy cái này
phải da chuyên sâu ở rất chuyên nghiệp
và phải quen rồi mấy cái khái niệm khó
nhà này rồi có thể
chữ mấy cái này tôi làm suốt rồi
có người từng Tôi tưởng mò vụ đấy tôi
làm tận à với đây tôi làm trang web đăng
nhập bằng đầy đủ Rất là mạng xã hội rồi
còn mò lại ngồi sửa luôn nha cho kệ tôi
tôi còn đóng góp ở trên cái tôi không
biết khoe với ông chưa Tôi có đóng góp
về trên cái thằng à Ở đây tôi cũng không
biết người hay tồn tại thôi tôi về tự mò
ghệ oa sự đóng góp cho thằng Credit cái
vụ đấy
anh không biết rồi có sao vẫn chắc chắn
còn tay mình nói đi
Ê mấy ông nên có cái danh hiệu gì đó cho
ai à
xe
tải mèo phải không Ngày Alo mèo biết rồi
đóng góp vòng thôi
thằng janus này bản chất Nó diễn đàn
kiểu ăn nó ẩn danh nên là thực ra nó
không trả về cả email luôn cơm anh tướng
ạ o
th kia là nên chả thấy dữ liệu gì đó nó
chẳng là cái gì cả
Ừ nhưng mà Hồi đấy tôi lại tôi mò được
thêm tài liệu nó là nó chả với nickname
và và
ảnh bìa ảnh đấy có thể là không phải ảnh
thật nó chị ảnh được tạo ra một cách
ngẫu nhiên hồi nhưng nó vẫn là ảnh này
tôi vẫn đóng góp về đây này nickname ao
ta chức hồi đầu gội đầu đúng nghĩa là
trả Return mày muốn cái ID trở về mỗi
ngày hay áp Al arabi trái nghĩa gì cả
nghĩa bằng đăng nhập bằng cái đít này
hồi đầu vô dụng ra lại chẳng 500 trả về
cái gì cả đấy
chung là thực ra là có một vài trường
hợp thì
bây giờ vẫn còn dư dả thời gian tôi vẫn
ngồi làm cùng cài cùng bé ông được nhé
em mới gặp phải ngồi cắn nhé người ông
mà cứ ham ham khó quá có thể thử nhớ mấy
ông khó hiểu kết hợp việc là cái trang
web mày ngồi làm sẽ lâu hơn tôi còn phải
làm trang web sau nữa sau trong web này
còn về hướng dẫn mấy ông làm cái trang
web quản lý trường nữa thử nếu thấy có
khi ở không kịp đâu nhỉ Không nên tham
quá thôi Làm cách một đi không có thế đó
cái một đi
vì tôi sợ không đủ này ra để ngồi dậy
cho mấy ông cả cái trang quản lý trường
em mình hơi bị tốn nhiều thời gian nữa
Ừ bởi Tôi vừa Tôi còn phải vừa làm thôi
vừa nói giải thích cho bé ông ấy chứ tôi
mua cốc dạo này đang ấy phải xong cái
trang này xong rồi cái tính năng cơ bản
lại lâu rồi
Anh hello đầu tiên thì bây giờ mình có
chơi đơn giản đó là mình à
em có cái HTM Alo alo Này Tống ở trong
cái cái cụ Linh này nhá nghĩa tự động
điện cho cô Linh ok chưa đơn giản
và cách làm của tôi nó sẽ trở dạng như
này à
10000 bình tĩnh cái này là đầy đủ thông
tin bởi vì là tôi là cái thằng Chính chủ
của cái áp này nên nó ra được này không
tin thôi còn nếu mà không phải chính chủ
thì tôi nghĩ là nó sẽ ra ít thông tin
đấy nó không có kiểu như ông tin ai đâu
à
Ừ để tôi xem nhé
nhà mình có tài khoản kết sắp khác không
nhỉ
này mặc định nó trả về chỉ có ngần nào
là được
nhỉ
phim hài chiếu thông tin hoài
ở đây đây đây mình tranh thủ vào con
biết bổ sung một vài cái gì
Anh Bình thường mấy thằng kia trả về
dưới đây chứ
nhỉ
nó lừa đấy
có một vài cái thì tôi là nó ý nhất có
cái này chẳng hạn Tôi không biết được là
người khác đăng nhập vào cái app của tôi
thì có cái này không mấy ông nên Hình
dung là bởi vì chính chủ nó đang đăng
nhập bằng Cái app này nên là nó sẽ lấy
được tất cả quyền nó sẽ lấy được bọc tất
cả thông tin và bìa những công ty công
khai ngay cạnh ạ Đấy nó lấy được có vài
người sẽ lý đúng không ạ Không phải là
người ta không Điền mà người ta còn ẩn
đi nữa cơ quan trọng như thế thì sẽ
không không có mình ở đấy mẹ mình không
ạ
Thôi mình cứ bắt chước là mình cứ dùng
mấy cái Hà mà bắt chước kiểu này đi ghét
mấy cái này đi chứ Dạ thôi
Ừ thôi Chẳng biết là tôi dùng để mua hai
hai nữa
dùng cơ để lấy gọi tao kem để làm gì để
mà về sau ông thể gọi lên api với ông
đấy lại thông tin gọi là reflect lại
thông tin của người dùng từ như thế
nhưng mà đừng bỏ qua
người dùng đăng nhập lại thì nước đó
đăng nhập lại thì ông cũng thể lấy lại
một phát nữa bởi vì nó luôn cấp lại cho
ông phải có kem ở nhưng mà thôi kệ nó sẽ
như sau Ừ tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ đẩy sang
cái pho đăng ký như tôi tưởng bạn để mà
với bất kỳ thời trang nào sẽ đẩy Sang
Phạm phòng đăng ký nó sẽ ổn hơn
thì mình sẽ
I read faq
thì mình sẽ có Cha là cha nha
chủ động inox in
Ừ tôi không thích dùng từ Core I5 cho
mày nữa Tôi thích dùng Shine và xài app
nó hay hơn
I say in sẽ vọng in law
à à
nhà vệ sinh
Mà tại sao nó bảo sang Đài nhỉ
a terrorist vậy
Ừ thế
ờ ờ ở đây sẽ điều hướng đi tơ này
direct này lô tô
ừ ừ
Khi mà mình sẽ kèm theo week
I fall kém thông tin người dùng này
chị
sẽ là đêm này
ba lá
em restore
ừ ừ
anh không truyền được cửa này
thế này
truyền một vài thông tin của người dùng
sang bên kia để mà
có gì mà điện sẵn ở phan đăng ký
Ừ Đợi thì đợi tí nhé vợ tương một tí
ngày là u dâu mày nghỉ
Ừ chắc nó là
bây giờ
ngủ giờ
à à
email lại đi
Ừ anh truyền
thế nào đây
Ừ mình không cần à Cái ID email à
anh rất nhiều ạ
âm thanh
tôi sẽ
sang bên này tạo file ghi restore
template
Em
ở quê tôi chưa Tạo à Linh cho mấy ông
xem nào Xin lỗi Xin lỗi
các bạn lớp trường sinh hỏi nhất 22 quên
đấy
là lớp trường tạo cho anh Linh gồm ít
nhé
pack ở đây restore này
R2 Chắc là Twister 2 nó có gì đẹp
cho xem
sẽ copy Crystal 2 về
hôm nay mình sẽ copy cái à
em sửa lại một tí
Vì sao logo đi này
trong dự án thực tế tôi có tranh thì nó
sẽ
nó sẽ dùng Facebook
ra Suite nó không
vì nó không kẹo rảnh mà gộp chung lắm
nhưng lại leo kiểu mình đang làm như thế
này Nói chung là tùy không
cả ngày khó bởi vì vài công ty nó áp
dụng thuật toán ario bây giờ hỗ trợ
tương đối rồi là bìa cái mấy cái Pocket
mới gần đây tôi đọc cái này có kít đây
này Nó hỗ trợ kiểu nó nhanh tiện mấy ông
thể tham khảo qua nói chung là tôi không
chê Galile bây giờ nó đã phát triển mạnh
thôi không chơi gì cả
à à
có ai cái vụ email này vì quay tượng
điên đấy thế cá như tội từng nói mấy ông
Nếu mày không để ý kỹ ở toàn bộ template
nó đều Thiếu cái nêm cho mấy cái này thì
cũng phải thèm đến đây mình nữa ở đây nó
sẽ ra
và lu này bằng à
Em soạn
Ừ nhưng mà mình là mình dùng cái gì nhỉ
Nhưng dùng à
Ừ nếu có ô đúng không
à à
được không mời tôi truyền so với này thì
tôi lại không truyền cái kẹo Ô mà tôi
truyền cậu ít không không biết cô được
không
cho anh anh nói chung với giờ tao tải
lại trang này mình nhớ là to Kem này đôi
khi hiệu lực rồi Tại sao khi mất ấy
đấy
Ô thế mình sẽ phải sang bên này ao lại
nè
à à
em ấm lại nha
anh em mình sẽ phải lấy sang bên ai tạo
một cái Alistar
ừ ừ
a distant à
này quýt này chính lecithin flash nên
này do nó sẽ bị mất người ông nên nhớ
nhá quýt này chứa season flash nên nó sẽ
chỉ kiểu này Nói một lần thôi
không biết được sang bên này lấy cái dữ
liệu kiểu gì nó trong sân à Ừ như thế
mình sẽ là phải xin
ừ ừ
à à
a z à chắc là thế
ở khu đi
Vì sao cho dù bé cũng được cô chẳng qua
khu nó cũng ghét nhưng đồng thời nó sẽ
kéo từ cái xin ra nghĩa là kéo ra sức
làm gì à Ông ông sẽ được khánh hiện là
kiểu dạng là ông sẽ khái niệm là kiểu
dạng mà ông lấy nó ra
Ừ ông ông lấy nó ra nhưng mà bản chất à
Ông nó vẫn còn giá trị ở đấy gặp khu tới
gà kéo hẳn nó ra sẽ xóa giá trị cũ là đi
dưới mình phải xóa cái đi anh sẽ không
dùng cái source online nữa số sao này
nữa
Tại sao mà mất về Tôi bảo nó sẽ dẫn
flash nên thành ra nó sẽ chỉ chút nó một
lần thôi bởi vì mình không thể đẩy nó
lên nhá mình mình cũng không lưu lại
trong chất sừng cả đấy làm gì có lâu cả
cũng như là mình cũng ah
không không nên để hai địa chỉ này chả
ai đấy Hay địa chỉ cả ấy nói chung và
lại trang nói chút à Thực ra tôi từng
thấy một vài chai như hến tải tại trang
được mất sư cái mình tự động Điền
à
Hôm nay mày ông thể điều hướng quá nhanh
rồi thức ra nói chuyện qua qua mấy cái
rồi mấy ông lý không Nó sẽ chuyển qua
cái gì đầu tiên nó sẽ nhảy sang bên này
sau đó thì buổi vừa vừa nãy tôi cung cấp
cho thằng ít Hấp rồi nó vẫn còn hiệu lực
đến hàng ra nó sẽ qua bên ai nó nó xong
rồi nói lyrics về đó lấy thông tin doris
về và nó quay quay ra đây nên à nếu
không thấy nó có lót một tí như thế thì
ra là điều hướng 23 phát rồi đấy ạ Em
email này mình sẽ lấy được email rồi
mình sẽ lấy được link à
cứ gái chưa Ờ
Ừ cái gì nhỉ Nên email thủy điện lên
trước thôi theo dõi đi avatar Linh nữa
hồi bỏ qua Linh
Chị Linh à
A cho người dùng tự điện đi Kệ ở Email
Em chưa có cả và ta đấy Nhưng mà thường
đăng ký chẳng ai cho Điền trước đó ta
phải nhé chồng mà không còn cửa quá
Ô thế Mình có thể kiểm tra trước đi kiểm
tra nếu có ta lấy dao ta luôn cũng được
Âm Nhạc
thì hơi khó bạn này tôi đang không biết
gì đấy
thế hiển thị ra ở đây bởi vì kiểu gì
mình cũng bởi vì người dùng Đăng nghiệp
rồi đăng nhập vào mạng xã hội rồi Hiểu
rồi Kiểu gì người dùng cũng sẽ
từ điển toàn bộ thông tin bằng những
thông tin mà người dùng đã cấp - vụ
password thôi đúng không Đúng không Đã
thì tôi có thể cho mình cái aristole và
hiển thị sẵn một loạt trên ở này nữa Cái
gì mình lấy được mình định chết trước
thế này là Zippo Lee và lưu lại trong Au
luôn cũng được để cho người dùng điện nó
quá vuốt đấy là một cách à
ở đây là một cách để tôi xem
ờ ờ
Ừ để lấy được luôn cả những chuyện với
Dung chẳng hạn thế à
nhập bằng nhằm ngay đâu Tự nhiên mình cứ
làm khó khăn hơn này Đấy thôi thôi
trót làm khó bản thân tôi sẽ làm khó nốt
nhé á
a a u a o đăng nhập bằng tài khoản kia
à à
có một cơ hội chợ Cái tháp id2 Facebook
ID ra sự gia sửa thế đợi một cách đó là
người ông sẽ mấy ông sẽ
chị Chị đăng nhập bằng một vài Voice đô
thôi Kiểu đi sao mày đi lá bay đi link
này đi anh chẳng hạn thế à
tôi một tí
ra trào xử lý phải đăng nhập ở ngày đoạn
này này cả
anh vứt cạnh tôi sẽ fastfood cái này vào
trong nhà hàm không không nên xử lý ở
router lại tôi làm hơi sai nữa tôi sẽ xử
lý nó ở
chỉ có bác
cái này thử xử lý nhanh mềm yếu thể để
đây được muốn cho
anh dồn
Anh quay ở đây là mình sẽ chấp nhận là
theo Email nhé ghét email I
ở đây thì mình sẽ đăng nhập các tài
khoản email mới
Ừ nhớ mà có rồi thì mình sẽ update
thường à Thì chắc áp nếp thì đây cả cho
update đây cả
em
có đi
update abrus hoa cà Ford
Everest tôi sẽ sử dụng đây ạ
anh theo email này nếu mà
à à
em chưa có thì mình sẽ tạo thằng mới
anh như này
dead đêm
ờ ờ
avatar game avatar
Ừ nó
thế này
khi đăng nhập
số
tài khoản này luôn này
ký để làm gì để mà điền nốt một vài
thông tin nữa bởi vì mình nghĩ gì Đăng
nhập bằng vài tài khoản này thế toàn bộ
những cái cột này nó phải là nun nun
Abel
anh Bởi vì lúc đầu phát nha sẽ rõ là
mình mới chỉ Điền trước những cô này
thôi những con kia chứ chưa tự động điên
đấy nó sẽ bao lỗi à
ừ ừ
khi bé hàm Ford Everest này lắm chỉ ra
đầu tiên nó sẽ kiểm tra Email tồn tại
tồn tại không Nếu mà tồn tại rồi thì nó
sẽ ghi tên về thằng rô luôn còn nếu mà
chưa tồn tại thì nó sẽ tạo thằng mới
theo những cái chưa mình truyền vào đây
này ra 2 à à
ờ ờ
mà Tại sao tôi tự nhiên đoạn Vừa rồi tôi
phải làm mất công như thế bởi Tôi muốn ở
đây tôi sẽ lấy được cái á
thằng Âu hoặc cả có thể kiểm tra nếu mà
bảo tồn tại thì bỏ qua mấy thằng ngày
Ừ đợi tô màu tím tôi tôi sẽ làm với cậu
nháy cho mấy ông dễ hình dung nhé à
cách Xóa ID
cho tôi tôi sẽ làm cái này mấy ông nhìn
mấy ông sẽ hiểu ngay Tôi đang muốn làm
cái gì à
ở
đâu này là xong trường hợp mà
Em email không có trọng hay đấy nữa đỡ
thì tôi đã ký kết hàng ngày lên
hai sẽ là ghét là khách gồm chỉ là nếu
cho em nhập thì sẽ như thế nào đấy với
cái này dùng trang đăng ký dùng cả lúc
mà đã bạn đăng nhập bằng nhau hoặc cả
chưa đăng nhập gì cả
ở với thằng Âu này khi bỏ đi qua này đi
này play hô đi này
anh hai đi bỏ mấy cái này bỏ hết đi em ạ
đi làm nha đi chơi bồ này
Ừ anh đi sẽ có 3 lưu cho nó là người tự
luôn này à
à à
Âm Nhạc
Ừ từ à
ca nhạc lấy từ our kiểu gì nhỉ
à à
Anh info house hour
Khi bữa trưa dùng ao Mà này là tôi phải
tra một tí đúng thông cảm nhé nhé
a a Woa ren
ngoài đền user này Vì sao gọi điện a nêm
Ừ đúng nhỉ
Ừ đúng rồi
à à
Thông cảm thấy được đấy
Ừ anh Đạt điều họ sẽ điều hướng
Em email và đầu ngôi mình chưa điện ở
trong mai mình sẽ có
A vidoe của Texas
xe
Limo cái gì có thể điên à anh bằng Email
này
các em ạ
ở Avatar này thì ra cái này vẫn bị sẽ bị
lỗi vì như tôi vừa bạc thì password nó
chưa được Điền em Thằng anh họ cũng sẽ
lỗi như thế này
Cho
tôi tải lại cha nó bị lỗi bởi vì A cái
tao kem này như tựa bảo nó chỉ ở tao
nghe dùng một lần Còn nếu mà ông muốn
thì tôi nhớ là vừa rồi nó cũng cái tích
cào là tablet
có phải nữa có thể có cái này thể dùng
nhiều lần nhưng mà thôi bỏ qua đi
ờ ờ
xe tải lại phát nữa này
Có
ai thấy tôi vừa nói không đó là cái
password nó sẽ phải luôn Abel Nghĩa lúc
Tại đây thì tôi sẽ lại phải sửa lại cái
tay một tí
à à
acc nè
you make me crazy Hamster
password
Bloom OOO
Em in your table mấy ông làm chuyên
nghiệp với cậu ngay Chú béo không vào tự
ý vào sửa đá tay luôn nhé mày không sẽ
phải tạo mai mai qua sân cái thứ về sau
20 trận gồm nhiều phết đấy
kiểm tra mà trong bảo ngu rô này có một
password không này Ừ nếu có thì mình sẽ
làm gì này
defo thì là gì không có đây phong thủy
cả
Tuy
nhiên trong trường hợp này hơi bị ngược
một tí để em mình đang sửa nên thành ra
mình phải kiểm tra đây là ngược lại đấy
và thực ra mình không cần mà mình không
còn robot các bạn này làm gì tôi sẽ cho
đấy Không có đâu Bác thì cả mình cần giờ
mình sẽ ở đây mình sẽ cho nó label có
thể được phép sống và mình sẽ dùng hàm
trên như này thấy hiểu là mình đang sữa
cục này nó em mình sẽ chặn myrosin này
FPT is my friend
Em hãy thì cái code này bây giờ sẽ có
thể chấm
ở
cột a password
Ừ nó quất đâu nhỉ
Ừ đợi tí nhé u xơ
thiệu cho Ép kiểu trễ lỗi tội lỗi tôi ở
Anh hiểu thôi
à à
cột lại là thêm cái Pocket này để làm
đấy
anh làm sao
xe tải loại này có password Kane Rooney
vô nghĩa lúc đầu khi mà tạo user thì có
thể là cột password thể chấm
Các bạn ơi
à à
31 City ở có giá trị
bắt buồn Điền city à
khi sex
em bật điện
em bỏ qua anh những cái này có thể bỏ
qua đi rồi tính à
Company ID cũng phải điên à
Sai sai Nếu mà ứng cử viên này đâu có
bởi vì mình chưa đầy cốt lên thì mình có
thể robot được đấy ạ
Anh Nô ba cái này nhá mà tôi sẽ xóa xóa
luôn cả phải đi
cần ràng buộc không á thường là không dữ
liệu thì sao nặng quá thì không cần ràng
buộc đâu
chị sẽ Make
My xin
enter Blues
I wanna Bồ Đào Nha cho dễ hiểu
này
anh Bởi vì à Rõ ràng được hay được gọi
rất nhiều Tôi sẽ làm cái này
Anh vào trong
ừ ừ
thứ ba ngày có code password có Nemo
tiếp theo của City
khi Bolero ô
a tiếp theo cột Company And I
là cities và tra đúng rồi nhưng con cái
này sẽ là
big in in
a big Win
gì đã con kia
ex2
ăn sai đấy
ex2 n cho anh say lại phải như này nằm
chuẩn đấy
chứ có phải được Có vẻ đúng
Anh sẽ trả lại nhé Ai đi không cần ạ
đang làm gì không ờ
Ừ ok chạy được ko
mô tả lại này
Mẹ nó bây giờ gần nhiều chẳng có gì chỉ
cần phải điền đã
quay lại này ấn ơi
em đợi đi nha
thằng này nó với ý mình dùng béo mà hai
au nào đó sport Tết Xa Nhà
sport Face Đúng rồi nhỉ
á hậu giờ
Ừ được rồi
à à Nhờ các bạn hãy sẽ sai đấy
khi nghe tôi sửa lại đây là
à à
ờ ờ atadi
thêm mảnh nhau thì vay đỡ nhớ hình như
là thế thì như là thằng này phải ưu thêm
bằng out ngồi ở
Khi
nào đi
nhé Đừng nhầm nhé ok không phải
ở ao Tho kiếm mãi
em yêu
bây giờ đi
À ra thế Điên à
anh alo
ý với điều kiện là thằng ngu de là phải
yêu cái gì gì đó nữa chứ Ừ đợi tao tí
nhá rồi thông tin
anh ạ
à à
Anh remix
đi
mua đồ rồi
Alo quần mua đồ
Anh nhớ nó yêu cái gì cái nhỉ
ở xa không Dạ đậu xanh như yêu ư
a-class the không có ok không phải thằng
ai
á hậu này
thế thôi nhớ thằng rescues là mặc định
có cái au gì gì đó thông cảm tôi đã chỉ
quá thôi không nhớ cái cha nó như thế
nào
ở vị trí theo kiểu Chị sẽ lo cho mấy ông
Lỡ rồi mò nốt à
Em thích Bắc hơi mất thời gian tính chưa
dùng này rồi tôi đi
à à
đây đây đây
I Miss Day
email I
ở đây đúng không Ông đây không
a a war không Không Phải Tôi vừa xem
nhầm à
không
anh không
về
sài thôi
ờ
ờ xã này đi sáng nay đi này yêu yêu đây
à
em có pin mà đâu ngay này nằm thế à
ở
đôla lại
phim hài
Ê Nhớ à vài cái không cần
Ừ Ok mình như vừa rồi tôi bảo là mình
dùng kéo gì nhỉ à
Ừ ok không phải là Âu tour
bỏ qua cái này
bỏ cái này
Em bỏ cái này một cái này
một file bỏ này bỏ cái nhẹ bớt đi rồi nó
xong được có tin là được anh em phải tin
tôi nó chẳng có sẽ như này à
thế này
tự động Điền ai
thì tại sao không mất đi nhá vì đâu nha
ok chưa Alo gái rồi dễ
ở Avatar Ngon
a c
sẻ nhạc Dura
vợ người ta
à à
a Cái thằng hyper này nó còn có cái á
triệu Kiểu như này
class để cho cái ảnh em bé
ừ ừ
Ừ hai cái đít đấy
Ừ cái bé tắm rồi nghỉ
kiến này có tác dụng gì
ở trận đấu kìa bò quay một Cẩm Khê
một ngày như thế thì À
cho biết nó là
332 mất trước hoặc rồi đi
ở tuổi tự khen tôi đó Sao mày không chỉ
cần điền password đã Xong rồi đăng ký
đúng không Ừ ok chưa dễ
để trong trường hợp mà như tôi đã bà là
đăng nhập quả đâu rồi Giả sử Bây giờ tôi
copy đường link này nhá Tôi mở ẩn danh
này nó sẽ phải điền đầy đủ thông tin này
Cô Đơn nhiều lúc đầu thì mình điền thông
tin chìa khóa avatar đúng không Tao ta
mình tôi nhớ không được nó cũng nên đi
bồ mà mẹ không cần mẫu buộc phải điền
lúc đâu Nhưng mà nếu mà đăng nhập bằng
mạng xã hội khác rồi thì mặc định nó sẽ
em định nó sẽ chở hàng á như thế Mày
không thấy không ngon chưa alo alo gái
rồi nháy lên anh em gái không đôi nào
đây mình à
Cho anh xin nghỉ
ở Đăng ký Đăng ký người ông Thế thì ra
nó dễ rồi à
Em làm đăng ký nhé
tôi lừa à
a password nó thì ra là phải có nhập lại
bắt buộc nữa
có gì cái này vậy cầm gia súc tích và
ừ ừ
Vì sao có giá Switch Gọi a
vẫn đường chẳng hiểu được
Ừ cái bấm mào gà rồi bấm đường link nó
không có gì ở bấm đúng không Cũng được
về để đấy Ok Rock in này
Em xài lắm Ok chúng mày xịn đấy Bây giờ
mình sẽ những cái pho mình sẽ nhảy đến
bên A Twister ở đây à Ô search history
à à
anh có nhớ không lầm lại ạ 3 cách đặt
Thằng này nó là ờ
có
thêm chữ đuôi in đằng sau không ạ Ngày
đẳng cấp cực hiệu Đang xử lý lại cỡ ngày
Đấy thế là xong
đỡ phải nghĩ force cấp Thứ tư số phức
tạp là chuyện chữ in những rau nhé thế
là được ý mà à
em chưa Tôi đọc một bên
anh cũng không phải là quy chuẩn của
thằng nào rồi
ô hay áo trắng quy chuẩn đi đây
à à
ở ngõ số đường sinh nhật password123
ngắn hạn
Ừ cái điện này không không quan trọng
mình vẫn cho đăng ký người thường thấy ở
đây này thì anh cái hàm này đúng không ạ
này thì à
à à
ờ ờ
là mày mình cần là thế nhưng mình cần
request Lấy toàn bộ thông tin về ngay
em ở đây trong trường hợp này chỉ thực
ra là bởi vì mấy cái này của tôi còn lại
đi xe bồ rồi tôi không không cho mấy
thằng bia lại nữa
Ừ đúng ạ nghĩa là mình không có nêm
email chỉ lấy một password thôi Cái này
thì ra mấy ông nên làm virus nếu không
sẽ kiểm tra nhưng mà vai biết ở đây được
ra nó hơi phức tạp một tí Viruss bình
thường nó có kiểm tra áo anh trường hợp
này mình có cạo có không
cho nên là thường là sẽ làm kiểu này ít
đau này
em
ở đây nhớ là tất cả
ở những có trách không biết hạn có sao
không
em biết luôn đấy tôi thử nhé Đấy một đấy
đi rồi
Mở hài đi
Ừ thôi nhá
số 1A
thử copy đường link này sang bên này
chaque Có vẻ có tác dụng này chị Tuyết à
chất là mình không cần đăng ký đó mình
chỉ cần cập những thông tin thôi thì sẽ
làm như nào out
Ừ giờ ngày
ờ ờ
ở đây tôi sửa lại đợi tí
ừ giờ này
I love they này
anh alo the weather
anh nghe này
Có ai đi là cái thằng đang đăng nhập này
ạ sau đó thì á update này
máy quét
A Gọi điện password kiểu ngay nó sóng
á nhon Còn nếu không thì sẽ là mình sẽ
đăng ký thôi mình sẽ là the class a
em biết ở đây nó sẽ gồm cả
password cả
Hà Nội tiết
các bạn name password này
Ừ
tao đó thì mình Âu luôn cái thằng ngu dơ
này
đi
bằng là ai
anh em xem đăng nhập với thằng anh xong
mình sẽ điều hướng đi đấy direct về
ở trang chủ rằng ăn đúng không ạ
Xin chào nhỉ Mình coi trang chủ lắm nhỉ
Ở đây không có trăm Master đấy Chả tác
dụng gì cả đấy như điều hướng và một
trang gì đấy lại khá như thế
cơ thủ thử trải nhà
anh không báo lỗi không báo lỗi tất cả
chạy thành công rồi
tôi thử vào xem bên users thôi nha
Em gái thằng thứ 101 này
our mở ra a password này Thực ra bán
buôn này sang mới rồi Các mốc này mình
phải mã hóa nó hát
anh giống như ông ạ
và Mike ngay Anh sẽ mã hóa nó như thế
thì tôi sẽ vứt password password về các
bạn nó sẽ luôn mã hóa hay tôi sẽ rất nó
trên này à
du lịch sử dụng nó ở dưới đổi password
thôi
Nghe có vẻ hợp lý có phải hợp bia à
password thôi đúng không Mình không cần
phải cập nhật lại nêm email vì rõ ràng
có điên Đâu đúng không này tôi thử
khi đăng nhập bằng ra nhé
anh
nguyễn này
Ừ ok chưa
Hào Môn Thừa quên tôi quên tôi rồi tôi ở
trong u dâu của tôi không có phim Abel
password nên nó không được đi ăn
chứ không phải không được đâu Ờ
ra tại đại tràng những vẫn được
nó lại nhảy vào vào nó update chứ không
phải là crash kok ấy vừa rồi là tôi đã
chỉ qua cho mấy ông từ đầu đến cuối hơi
bị tốn thời gian một tí nhưng mà từ đầu
đến cuối á cái kiểu về
oau cái gì đó để mà đăng nhập bằng mạng
xã hội khác nóng ạ bây Thực ra để mà làm
một mạng xã hội nữa đẩy rất là nhanh
nhưng ông ấy ông hiểu rõ cơ chế rồi tôi
thử lại trong mấy ông nhé để tôi thử
bằng bất kì thằng nào class sẻ với cân
nặng chỉ sợ là
tạo tay tạ tội ác nó hơi Thuận công thôi
để unique này email chúng vẫn được là
thế hơi sai đấy
sửa nhà
ạ Bạn ấy thì mình lại Ạ tạo cái á
các file
lại tạo phải ăn tơ lại cập nhật
ừ ừ
Anh vừa là vừa lạ
ẩm thực ra có thể chùm Có thể chúng
trong trường hợp là vừa đăng ký làm à
ứng cử viên vừa đăng ký hát Slow và lá
Min hạ thế
Ừ Chắc không sao đâu
Ừ kệ chó đăng ký nhiều cho vui
khi người ấy
get Black của tôi làm cái này nha nhiều
nhé Vậy kiểu gì cũng phải làm à
được
lắm ơi
ờ ờ
ừ ừ
à à
anh không thử Gà bây giờ về các bạn Mình
chưa có cái gì và mới được quay tính sao
đã
I read read file
hay checkin email này
Chúng tôi đọc một cách lén chui xong
không hiểu
An đăng ký làm đồ án
khi được ông inbox riêng tôi trên đi đi
con nhé có hại 12 ông gì đó Đang đang có
vấn đề đang đang nghỉ rồi ông sẽ được
thay thế mấy ông anh
ơi Bun ơi
Ừ đúng rồi lyrics điều hướng quyền quyền
quý
à à
I eat less
dễ như trò đùa vậy
á
nhon này không ạ Rồi mình sẽ làm gì anh
sẽ sửa lại ở bên này thì đây là một cái
là huyết áp
à à
anh
Coffee copy
mỹ nhân showbiz
để tạo một cái ghi lắm
đã biết map ạ
đội là Iraq
a song
em xong đấy lẽ không Vẫn chưa đùa bấm
này
Anh đã bảo Linh đâu Xin lỗi vợ tôi ờ
à à
ờ ờ
anh
có Alo em xong rồi đây chị lo
Ừ ông một cấu hình xong này lập tức là
ngon lành ngay thế này Ở họ có avatar
Đàm Hoàng Cho Tiểu Thư chị ạ chị mà
à
Xong rồi Lincoln cũng thế Mình cần tương
tự thì thôi làm có thư viện hỗ trợ rồi
thì béo làm lại nhanh mà
Ê
mấy ông Nghĩa là tôi sẽ mò thêm một
tiếng rưỡi nữa không là người có chuyện
đấy tôi được là mấy hôm nay
nghe nói chỗ nào Thực ra cái này để tôi
bảo rồi Đấy Cách Một nó thực ra nó vẫn
dễ còn cách 2 thì à cấu hình đoạn Kiều
lăng nhăng hơn một tí nữa Nhưng khi mà
cấu hình được xong thì nó cũng sẽ nhanh
như thế thôi ông thêm bất kì thấy mạng
xã hội nào thì nó sẽ rất nhanh như thế
ông chị lên trang đấy để mà đăng ký áp
sau đó thì ông nhập cái ID với Suite thế
sau không ạ Đấy
Ừ làm giữ cái hay ở mấy ông cũng khen
tôi 200 tôi tự khen rồi
Đấy người ta gọi viết tự thưởng
Ok nghỉ được là
mấy bữa hôm nay tôi bảo thực Bạn rất bận
mấy ngày hôm chưa tôi nhỉ Mà
nghỉ đi nghỉ mát Xong rồi có bị gì đây
này sắc mặt anh cao thiếu lên hôm nay
cũng đi làm cả ngày ở trên công ty xong
về dậy nữa thế là tôi chờ hôm nay con
muộn không có tâm sự này cha mày Chán
nghe tâm sự biết được nó chỗ chưa tổng
hợp câu hỏi hôm nay cũng chưa trả lời
câu hỏi gì ra để buổi hôm sau tôi sẽ
tổng hợp câu hỏi từ mấy bữa trước cũng
đang động từ mấy bữa trước với tổng hợp
với câu hỏi thứ bảy anh em mình sẽ tâm
sự nhiều hơn và trả lời nhiều câu hỏi
hơn đó ông ạ Còn à Bọn mày sẽ tạm nghỉ
đấy đã bởi vì hôm nay cũng
hơi quá tôi nghĩa hơi quá cái nước xong
bé ông người ở hôm nay còn nhiều cái mới
vì tôi nghĩa là mấy ông cũng thấy cốc
hôm nay thời gian khá ngắn nhà qua về
cái lôgích cái cách xử lý thì nó đúng là
rất là mở về mấy ông thôi đúng không
Nhưng mà tôi khẳng định là mấy ông vừa
rồi còn được xem trực tiếp chứ nếu mà
Mấy ông tự mò thì tôi không biết mày
không tự mò những có thể làm nhé và đọc
tài liệu nó còn sẽ khó chịu Nhưng mà nếu
không thấy vừa tự mò tài liệu thì cũng
cũng mất cong rồi mà đúng không Tôi tôi
bảo tôi chưa biết về ai ngoài tôi chưa
biết tôi nhưng mà tôi đã biết về cái vụ
mà đăng nhập vào mạng xã hội khác rồi mà
tôi còn phải màu như thế không biết là
mày ông sẽ ngồi mò mất công như là nữa
ở nhà ông tra trên mạng thì cũng ít
người điều chỉnh thế đó người ta có thể
là chỉ cho kiểu lụa liền một mạch đều
chuẩn thì thì lại không phù hợp với việc
là nếu mà ông gặp vấn đề gì đó giống như
tô vừa rồi không biết cách giải quyết
như thế nào không ạ nhưng tôi nghĩa là
sẽ có vài lúc thì tôi sẽ phải mò Trực
tiếp trước mặt mấy ông để mấy ông biết
cách đi bốc cái là tội không thấy có vấn
đề gì sai cả để mấy ông nhìn nhìn khía
cạnh của một Suneo xử lý nhà thôi Nhưng
mà mấy ông cũng tránh việc làm tôi không
làm mấy ông đừng có làm gì không ạ
rồi ra về sau mình xử lý mọi thứ nó khá
nhanh mà không đến nỗi là kiểu dạng này
Mình nhà tôi đã từng gặp vài vài hàng
thầy nói Thấy sữa dậy của tôi kêu thầy
ngồi mò không không biết cách đi bớt đi
thì ngồi màu rất là lâu rồi thì xóa Từng
dòng cốt đi kiểm tra lỗi cả với Vân hãy
thưởng thế nó xa tệ khi mình biết cái gì
bóp rồi nó giải quyết nó nhanh mượt hơn
được hết à
ờ ờ
à à
Ừ ok Chắc là hôm nay tạm kết thúc ở đây
thôi Có gì hẹn gặp
Ê mấy ông vào không Thấy bệnh nhé không
vậy thì sẽ tâm sự nhiều hơn có
nói chung hoa trả lời các câu hỏi này
ông sao nhé